events to mark the 100-day countdown to
the start of the tokyo games were
necessarily low-key the city has just
raised its kovid 19 alert level and
government experts say japan is heading
into a fourth wave of infections
organizers though are resolute in their
commitment to the event
going ahead and have no hesitation in
saying that the games will take place
and they'll be the safest games possible
all of the counter measures have been
put in place to deal with covert
to ensure that the public uh the
athletes and all of the other
participants are safe
we can expect that that emotions will
will run even higher
because of the significance of the world
being together
for the first time in a pandemic
situation
there are so much expectations from the
world community
eleven thousand athletes will compete at
the games the international olympic
committee say being vaccinated
isn't a prerequisite for taking part but
many countries
are hoping they will be able to offer
their athletes the option
of getting vaccinated the athletes and
the officials are going into tokyo the
world is going to tokyo so in terms of
looking after the health and well-being
of the athletes and also giving them
that confidence that they
they have been vaccinated is going to be
very important to their performance
the torch relay is an event designed to
raise awareness and
interest levels in the games but the
most recent poll of japanese public
opinion
suggested that more than 70 percent want
the event
cancelled or postponed and matsuyama
city
has just called off its leg of the relay
due to rising coronavirus cases
we have medical professionals here
questioning why the games are going on
saying it's a too big a risk
despite all that it is going on it's
going on because the international
olympic committee
lives off television revenue and it must
get these games on television
secondly the japanese state has invested
perhaps 15 billion dollars in these
games
prime minister suga i think is staking
his claim
to perhaps extending his prime
ministership on making these games
successful so the japanese public cannot
back off and so the games go on tokyo
sold itself as a safe pair of hands when
it won the right to host the games in
2013.
that claim is now being tested in a way
few would have thought possible
andy richardson al jazeera